chicken stir fry with rice noodles
some of the best street food i've ever
eaten was in asia every one of those
little markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and you'd be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're gonna soak our noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water over the
rice noodles
soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got a wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin and to cut it into strips
take your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half like a sort of
scallop
like that
we call this butterfly in the chicken
take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken what it does it sort of flattens
it allows you to slice it
even thinner
and the thinner the slices of the
chicken the sort of crispier it gets the
quicker it cooks
slice it in half
just start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finally slice
garlic
the thinner the garlic
the crispier
this is a
young
tender
broccoli just slice them down
i want a bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one-third of your protein
chicken
a dish that takes literally minutes to
put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil
get a pan really nice and ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
[Music]
once you've started to sear off the
chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
and see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that garlic's getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
feels strange putting raw broccoli
in like that normally
we'll blanch it in boiling water dry it
out but
you want that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
it's exactly what i want now take that
out
give your pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
wok
really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing
this quick stir fry very classic two
eggs
in
[Music]
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it
at the side of the pan
lightly season
the eggs
noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that
a really nice mix
you want the egg to sort of almost
bring the dish together
that egg's cooked
make sure you've got that nice
even distribution of
chicken
broccoli
garlic
lovely
and then just finish that fresh lime
and then you have a very
simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
homemade gnocchi making your enoki is so
simple to do yet the results are
absolutely stunning and it's a great way
of using up leftover baked
potatoes can make noki just with flour
and eggs however the potato gives it a
nice light sort of creamy fluffy texture
cut them in half take your spoon
and scoop
the inside of those potatoes
i'm using leftover baked potatoes but
this really works as well with leftover
ball potatoes two choices you can get a
fork and sort of mash the potato and get
it nice and light and fluffy or
this little gadget is called a ricer i
suppose it's a posh word
for a potato masher just squeeze gently
you can see how nice and light it is
almost like fluffy little strands of
potato
you can do this when the potatoes are
hot
it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now
a nice spoon of okata ring a little
touch of salt and pepper it's really
important to season the mixture as we go
along otherwise the nokia becomes really
bland flour over the ricotta sieved so
there's no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now
make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft
pliable ball of dough
give that a really good mix
get some thyme flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant and it's
just a really nice herb and with the
ricotta
it tastes brilliant just pick the little
tips the time flowers
next flour your hands generously and
knead the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth
as it starts to get a little bit wet
and just add a little touch of flour we
want something really nice and soft now
don't overwork it
it stops the nokia from expanding when
it hits the pan
that's exactly what i want a nice sort
of soft
fragrant ball cut the ball in half
lightly flour
the hands and just roll it
gently
just think of a a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now
lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi it doesn't stick
cut the dough into bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down
why i want my knocking to look like a
pillow
and for me the most important part there
is that not one of them are identically
the same shape
water on
bring up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there
lightly flour your hand
lift up the nokia
in to the rolling boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom and let them simmer and
they start to sort of tell you they're
cooked when they start floating get a
pan on
get that nice and hot now they're just
starting to come up to the top and you
can continue cooking them like that i
like blanching them in the water taking
them out and then frying them to study
the gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying
pan
gently lift up and look
they've doubled in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside
nokia loves fresh pepper
so
pepper in
[Music]
you can see as i start turning them got
this really nice little sort of
brown color
and they're almost popping up now like
little parcels so i want them nice and
sauteed both sides but light
and creamy
in the center
fresh garden peas
in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of
bernoulli flavor on the end
beautiful
put a little bit of fresh thyme over the
peas and then finally i want to lift it
up fresh lemon zest the lemon over
[Music]
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated parmesan cheese give
your vegetable attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook and
absolutely stunning spicy sausage rice
whatever you're cooking the secret to
making great food is to ensure you're
locking every last ounce of flavour in
that pan and this spicy sausage rice
does exactly that
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
my mouth and my pepper
slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked peppers in
a bit of garlic two nice cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off and the real flavor of
that
spicy italian sausage is going to come
through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavor and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with merguez or cheeto
a teaspoon
paprika in give it that really nice
smoky flavor
rice in
and we're going to sort of basically
sear the rice we call it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of soda
the rice for 30 seconds and it takes on
all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice
turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring onions in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]